immigration it's the system that brought
you Albert Einstein yo-yo MA and me and
yes obviously marry kill
respectively immigration is the subject
that Trump campaigned on the hardest and
as president his tone hasn't exactly
softened I told my people yesterday our
country's fault with all our systems for
our country's full can't come in our
country is full what can you do we can't
handle anymore our country is full can't
come in I'm sorry he's right he's right
our country is totally full I mean just
take a look at it the thing is
absolutely packed there is simply no
room here I mean maybe if one of these
guys dies or something but until then
there's there's nothing we can do it is
obviously not that simple and in Trump's
more reflective moments seen here he
actually claims there is one kind of
immigration that he wants legal
immigration it's the thing that he and
his political allies will tell you they
love I want legal immigration I want
great people to come in
I want legal immigration I believe legal
immigration is good for our country
I believe that legal immigration isn't
my views on immigration are simple and
I've summed them up many times in just
four words legal good illegal bad
I do not like that man Ted Cruz I do not
like him in the news I do not like what
he just said I do not like his boxy head
I do not like him wearing glasses I do
not like him kissing arses
I wish he'd never get one vote that man
Ted Cruz can lick my scrubs we actually
agree on this legal immigration is good
that is a popular opinion both among
those who see immigration as
foundational to America and among
economists who largely agree that
increases economic growth about 13% of
the people in this country are
immigrants three-quarters of whom are
here legally so this system affects a
lot of people and with all the talk
about illegal immigration the flaws in
the legal pathway which arguably helped
fuel illegal immigration often kept
ignored so tonight let's talk about our
legal immigration system because there
are a lot of misconceptions about a
process that to be fair most Americans
have never experienced and a key
misconception is captured in a phrase
that you hear all the time both from
politicians and from ordinary voters we
want to let people in legally get in
line and we want to let people in
legally they have to do it the right way
they have to get in line come legally
and wait in line like all of them there
are a lot of people from all around the
world that are in line and waiting to
come in here and I don't think that they
should be able to come in ahead of all
these people that have been really
struggling to get here right get in line
and look that is an appealing phrase but
it's significantly more complicated than
that as you could probably tell from
that woman's reaction I'm guessing the
closed captioning for which is probably
woman thinking the because the
truth is for those who want to come here
there is no one line to get in the lies
that the lies that do exist can be
prohibitively long or have sudden dead
ends and for many people and this is
really important there simply isn't a
line at all and if you think it will
hold on my ancestors waited on line not
necessarily for America's first hundred
years there were no federal immigration
laws so coming here the right way
basically just meant not slipping as you
walked down
gangway now since then our immigration
system has evolved into one with
complicated and convoluted restrictions
take country caps when it comes to most
types of green card which allow you to
be a lawful permanent resident no more
than 7% of immigrants accepted each year
can come from any one country what that
means in practice is that big countries
with a lot of would-be immigrants like
China India and Mexico are subject to
the same numerical caps as tiny ones
like Malta which is so tiny that's
actual size in fact that's actually
Malta we borrowed it and put it in this
box to show you how small Malta is and
it's not just numerical caps the whole
system has a lot of restrictions on who
exactly can come here in fact the best
way to understand it is that there are
just four paths to permanent residency
or citizenship family you're related to
someone who's already here employment
meaning you were offered a job here good
luck you won the Visa Lottery which I'll
explain later or bad luck you're a
refugee or seeking asylum and the number
of people going through each path is by
no means equal proportionally they
should probably look a lot more like
this so so let's start with the way that
most immigrants come here family
sponsorship about two-thirds of green
card holders come through the family
based system which makes sense families
provide support and some I'm told like
each other but but to Donald Trump
family based migration is a scourge as
you can tell from how he refers to it
chain migration is not a good thing
chain migration is there we have to end
chain migration then you have chain
migration chain migration
a guy comes in stone-cold killer in many
cases a guy comes in and then you have
to bring his aunt his uncle his father
his grandfather his grandparents his
third least by a different marriage okay
that is so wrong in so many ways it
would honestly be hard for a fact
checker to assess it that couldn't even
be described by The Washington Post
bottomless Pinocchio which is an actual
thing they do now and which for the
record sounds like an all-nude strip
club for wooden puppets because because
bringing family members over is not
nearly as easy as Trump makes it sound
for a start you can only sponsor close
relatives at most that is a spouse child
sibling or parent no aunt no uncle no
grandparents no third niece by a
different marriage and anyone who comes
in has to pass rigorous background
checks which tends to weed out any
stone-cold killers and that Shane as you
definitely should not put it can move
very slowly because those country caps
that I mentioned earlier apply to many
categories of family based immigration
so if you're trying to bring your
sibling over from China the government
is currently processing applications
from 2006 if they're in India 2004 from
Mexico January of 1997 that's 22 years
ago and who knows what they'll be doing
22 years in advance aside of course from
Pat Sajak because I guarantee he'll
still be standing by a wheel selling
vowels he doesn't own until the
Sun dies
and yet the family sponsorship system is
still seemingly too permissive for Trump
who wants to limit it to just spouses
and children meaning you could no longer
sponsor for instance your parents to
immigrate here although interestingly he
seemed fine with one high-profile
exception president Trump's in-laws
slipping in and out of a Manhattan
Federal Building where they took the
oath of US citizenship sources tell ABC
News that First Lady Melania Trump
sponsored her Slovenian born parents
Victor and Amalia nobs I know it's not
the important part here but I should
point out milania's mom is 74 making
Trump exactly one year younger than his
mother-in-law and while there are plenty
of spouses out there who probably should
be closer to their in-laws that is
simply not the way to do it
so that is the family-based path which
of course only works if you have a close
relative in America and it frankly
doesn't hurt if she happens to be in a
loveless marriage with the president now
if that is not an option for you you
might try the employment-based path the
way that pathway usually begins is an
employer in America sponsors you and you
come here on a temporary work visa but
it is temporary you might be able to
renew it
if your employer likes you but there can
be limits on how many times you can do
that and even getting a work visa in the
first place can be very difficult you
have to fit within narrow categories
there is our one that's for religious
workers p1a that's for athletes h-2a
that's for farmworkers c3po 40-feet
British robots and r2d2 for their
common-law husbands it's a it's a
complex system I myself came over on an
o1 visa which is for persons with
extraordinary ability in the arts
[Music]
really thinking deep down and you
certain work pieces are so hard to get
highly skilled people get turned away
take a canal ball he's the founder of a
very successful Indian company called
Snapdeal he went to college in the US
and just watches he's interviewed on
stage at a conference in India about why
he ended up creating a company there
rather than staying here I got a job at
Microsoft it's quite happy you know the
Indian tech guy wanted to work at
Microsoft and and they applied for my
visa which got rejected now you're stuck
and you're getting deported back to your
country what do you do so you decided to
come back and start a company here thank
God okay well I'm glad that that story
worked out well for India but it's
frankly not a great result for America
is it who helped educate him and then
for some reason forced him to go
innovate somewhere else instead honestly
I respect canal bar for not going full
pretty woman on a u.s. immigration
office big mistake huge and it is worth
noting just getting a work visa does not
mean you're going to end up staying here
because converting it into a green card
can be difficult to practically
impossible depending on your skill level
and where you're from
you need your employer to choose to
sponsor you again and there aren't many
green cards to go round only around
140,000 of them are granted every year
basically think of getting a work visa
as getting a backstage pass to see BTS
sure it'll allow you to hang around for
a bit but you're probably not going to
end up becoming part of the band and
look I can tell you from experience here
living on a visa can be very stressful
and involves having to jump through
endless costly hoops I used to have to
file for extensions to my visa every
year hoping they'd be granted and had to
leave the country every 11 months to go
to the American Embassy in London to get
a physical stamp in my passport allowing
me to travel and I was constantly
constantly worried that I would not be
allowed to come back and here's the
thing even when you are approved for a
green card there might not be one
available for you because those country
caps that I mentioned also apply to
employment-based immigration so if you
come in from
say India your estimated wait time can
be ridiculously high watch is one boy
living in America finds out how long his
dad might have to wait so your dad is
applying for a green card for himself
and your family and then you is gone and
looked at this application and approved
it well problem is that there's a
waiting line for green card and that
line is really long for India though
very well will be about sixty years by
the time you dad gets a green card and
if I'm doing my math right dad will be
over a hundred and I'll be 71 well
nearly you'd that'll be dead but yeah
you will be you'll be 71 or dead or dead
you could be as dead as your very dead
dad but overall your point is a good one
there kid so together the family and
employment paths make up around 80
percent of legal immigration but what
about if you are not related to somebody
here and you aren't already
highly-skilled well that brings us to
the luck categories if you are lucky you
could come to America through something
called the diversity Visa Lottery which
I'll let the present explain so that you
know exactly what it isn't
they call it Visa Lottery I just call it
a lottery where countries come in and
they put names in a hopper they're not
giving you their best names common sense
means they're not giving you their best
names they're giving you people that
they don't want and then we take them
out of the law of lottery and where they
do it by hand where they put the hand in
a ball like probably what's in their
hand or the worst of the worst
okay there's just not time to break down
how wrong everything he just said one
but suffice to say Tron can expect a
visit from bottomless Pinocchio any day
now because because everything about
what he just said is wrong the country
the person comes from is not involved
they don't give us anyone the people who
win are vetted and obviously it's not
done by hand 22 million people applied
in 2017 does he honestly think we made
one of those spinning bingo hoppers for
22 million ping pong balls what actually
happens is anybody who lives in a
country with low immigration rates to
the United States can enter themselves
into a computer run non bowl based
lottery for the chance to win something
called a diversity visa and out of the
millions of people who enter only 50,000
win so your odds of winning that lottery
to come into the country are about the
same as your odds of getting shot once
you get here basically if you win
congratulations for now
so so the visa lottery is the longest
oval of long shots
it's honestly barely even worth talking
about which brings us to our final
category here bad luck that is basically
refugees and asylum seekers fleeing
terrible situations and America has long
prided itself with some reason on the
fact that it's led the world in terms of
refugee resettlement accepting more
refugees annually than any other country
but as you probably know Trump does not
care for that he has attacked the asylum
system repeatedly and while Obama set
the annual cap on refugees at 110,000 in
his last year in office
Trump slashed it to 45,000 the next year
and 30,000 the year after that at this
rate next year's cap will be reduced to
just a zayeed at which point Trump will
probably make his campaign slogan get
rid of Zayat and if you're thinking if
you think he'd Trump might have a change
of heart if he just heard what some of
these refugees are fleeing you're wrong
about that
take Nadia Murad a Yazidi woman who was
abducted by Isis in Iraq she fled to
Germany after they killed her family won
a nobel prize for her advocacy and
actually got to tell her story to
Trump's face in the Oval Office recently
and what you're about to see is the
second time she specifically mentioned
to him that her family was killed and
watch just how little he has been
listening all this happened to me they
killed my mom my sickest brother they
left behind them they now they kill them
what are you doing where are they now
she just told you three words
ago that is the US president displaying
a level of indifference to human
suffering rivaled only by robots and
housecats
they really don't give a and things
could get even worse there are now
reports that Trump's White House is
weighing whether to cut the number of
refugees we admit to zero next year zero
and if they do that then please tell me
what is the right way for refugees to
come in then and that is the point here
for all of their talk about how fine
they are with legal immigration this
administration has worked hard to reduce
it as much as possible across the board
in his first year
Trump supported a bill that would have
cut legal immigration into this country
by half and while that bill went nowhere
he's made countless procedural tweaks
gumming up the process for coming here
legally which helps explain why the time
it takes to process an application has
jumped 46 percent since 2016 some
immigration attorneys are now calling
those changes the invisible wall and
just last month Trump put another brick
in that wall when the administration
issued what's called the public charge
ruling and making the path to permanent
residency much more difficult for any
would-be immigrants who fails to meet
income standards or is deemed likely to
use public assistance like food stamps
public housing or Medicaid that could
profoundly change who gets to call this
country home advantaging the well-off
and disadvantaging anyone they ever
think might have greater needs and when
Ken Cuccinelli acting director of US
Citizenship and Immigration Services was
asked how this could possibly square
with America's ideals his answer wasn't
great would you also agree that Emma
Lazarus's words etched on the Statue of
Liberty give me your tired your poor are
also part of the American ethos they
certainly are give me your tired and
your poor who can stand on their own two
feet
and who will not become a public charge
hold on that's not what it says you
can't just add lines to a poem they're
totally invalidated premise you can't
say in the words of Emily Dickinson
because I could not stop for death he
kindly stopped for me and then we
totally a lot death has a big fat
dick
you can't do that you're fundamentally
changing the intended meaning also it's
not just that it's addition to the poem
is terrible is that what he took out is
really important there give me your
tired your poor your huddled masses
yearning to breathe free because as
corny as it might sound America at its
best isn't about who you are when you
arrive it's about who you want to become
the yearning part counts and
that doesn't have to mean that everyone
who wants to come gets to come but if
you are going to say getting line to
people you should at least make sure
they actually have a line to stand in
and right now these are the only
pathways that exist and we should be
having a serious conversation about
whether they work smoothly enough which
they do not whether this is the right
balance between the categories and
whether we've defined the categories
correctly I think Trump for his part has
made it pretty clear that his ideal
system would be in two tiers split
evenly between rich Norwegians and
future wives personally personally I
think a lot more people should be let in
in general but I will admit this is
subjective and I am biased here I have
been through this system and I can tell
you it's rough when I finally got my
green card years ago it was sent to the
Daily Show
and they surprised me with it at work
for his emptying it to me with a slice
of apple pie and a Budweiser as a joke
thing is I was so relieved I nearly
burst into tears and that is when I
realized I'd been worried about my
immigration status every single day and
I was very very lucky I had a lot of
help and more importantly I had a path
to come here it's the path that has led
us all to sad Zuzu's mildly interesting
explain train but for many people there
is literally no way to come in the right
way and if I was one of them and Donald
Trump told me to just get in line and
come in the right way I think I would
have been well within my rights to quote
the other immortal words of Emily
Dickinson hope is the thing with
feathers also you don't know what the
you're talking about you
idiot there has a big fat dick
you